au lycée des métiers de l'optique de
mort et les sujets abordés sont variés
l'enseignement professionnel mais aussi
l'internât ou encore la filière
sport-études
le ministre veut aussi défendre son
projet de loi pour l'école de la
confiance sur ce sujet là je voudrais
quand même dire à tous que je suis
frappé de voir que les démos nantes de
mobilisation se font sur des choses qui
ne sont pas exacts on a dit qu'on
voulait affaiblir ou même supprimer les
directeurs d'école c'est complètement
faux on veut les renforcer on a dû qu'on
voulait diminuer ou supprimer les écoles
primaires rurales
c'est complètement faux avec le projet
de réforme de l'école mais aussi de
l'enseignement professionnel et du bac
les sujets d'inquiétude sont nombreux à
chapelle voland un petit groupe de
professeurs du collège voisin est venu
défendre une classe pourquoi vous êtes
là et bien pour se battre contre les
suppressions de postes à bletterans on
gagne sept élèves et on perd une classe
on va passer à des classes à 32 élèves
et on se demande où est l'égalité des
chances vendus par notre ministre loin
des manifestants la visite se poursuit
dans cette petite école de village un
modèle en matière de développement
durable mais aussi un exemple
d'enseignement en milieu rural tout le
monde ici veut garder l'école et le
ministre est rassurant que je lui ai
tout dit pour que ces écoles ne soit
jamais supprimé et qu'on reste dans
cette ruralité vraiment tout se passe
très bien c'est un milieu familial tout
le monde est content dernière étape de
la journée
le lycée le corbusier de lons le saunier
avec cette fois encore un comité
d'accueil
le message qu'on veut faire passer aux
ministres aujourd'hui c'est vous venez
dans notre jura vous venez passer une
journée dans le jura regardez bien où on
vit regardez comment ça s'organise nous
on est sur le terrain tous les jours on
a des idées à vous proposer
écoutez nous parce que là ça se fait
sans nous et les enseignants sont bien
décidés à se faire entendre dans la rue
demain lors d'une nouvelle journée de
mobilisation